How to get to the point in conversation? By the
end of this video, I'm going to be sharing tools
with you that will help save you time fluffing
around in conversation. Also increase and build
a culture of psychological safety and make
you a far better leader and educator by
increasing your clarity as well. I'm
Chad Littlefield, let's get to the point.
So first, I want to share about some
world-renowned leaders that when you
hear and think of the way that they navigate and
get to the point in conversations it'll blow your
mind a little bit. I then want to share a really
practical tool that you can use as an anchor
in any meeting any conversation to always
get back to the point. Because the problem
is that sometimes conversations wander and
so even if you get to the point of something
you go down a rabbit hole and you got to get back
to the point and so I'll give you a tool that will
serve as an anchor that no matter where you are
in conversation. No matter how long you've worked
with a group. No matter how long you've been
in conversation you can get back to the point
using this tool and then I want to combine wisdom
from two of my mentors that entered one each side
of my brain and formed a absolutely brilliant
strategy to actually cut a conversation in half
and separate out the fluff from the heart of
the matter. Jesus, Buddha, Gandhi and Rosa Parks,
can you imagine any of these four leaders figures
historical beings walking into a room and saying,
"Hey, how was your weekend?", I'm sure they probably
did it. I'm sure they probably chatted about you
know stuff the superfluous chit chat of life.
But these are people and some of the
best most renowned leaders are masters
of getting to the heart of what matters
and here's their secret. They had such a strong
and compelling and clear purpose and intention
that it rang through and emanated from everything
they said and did. If you want to elevate your
ability to get to the heart of the matter be as
intentional and purposeful as them. You know Priya
Parker says, "Meet for purpose not for time."
How often are you in a conversation and you're not
exactly sure why until you're like halfway through
it or something. Meeting for purpose not for time
and stating your intention always in the first
few minutes of a conversation is your anchor.
It's like you tossing an anchor to the point to what
you want to get done. What you want to discuss
or what you want to solve or unpack or whatever
else. It's the anchor and so anytime you go off
path you can come back to it. Second tool that my
once upon a time mentor now business partner
Will Wise shared with me is this idea that this
metaphor steering into the curve. Now this is he
didn't invent this metaphor and if you have
never gotten in a car accident it's a little bit
hard to relate to or if you've never been skidding
around off an accident ramp, it's a little bit hard
to relate to. But imagine that you're going off an
extra ramp and your car your tires lose friction
you start sliding. The best thing you can possibly
do in that tense moment is actually steer into the
curve. Meaning, turn the wheel the way that looks
like it's going to make you crash harder and worse
and that's actually the way to get out of thatslide.
Now, you know before you fully implement that
maybe google another video about extreme
driving to you know check that. The idea
here is the metaphor if you want to get to the
heart of the matter you've got to steer into it.
So, often I see conversations or I hear
secondhand or even third hand about a conversation
of he said she said whatever. Where people
are trying to get to the heart of the matter
in this roundabout way and you just can't
like it just it leads to passive aggressive
communication almost every time and so cutting
to the heart of the matter what I would invite
you to do is point out the elephant in the room. In
fact, one of my mentors Eric Tyler who wrote a book
called the best advice so far and so I do think
this is kind of the best advice so far. He said
that, "Once you say something half the power leaves
it or once you say something half the awkwardness
leaves it." I think that's true and valuable to keep
in mind when you're trying to get to the heart of
the matter. Because oftentimes we feel like,
"Oh, like I can't get to the point because it's too like
raw. It's too there's too much conflict in
bed in it. There's two that we have some fear
around just cutting straight to it", I'm saying like
this is what we need to talk about right now and
yet oftentimes as soon as we say it as soon as we
speak it out half the power leaves it right there
and then it becomes a conversation you can talk
about it. The longer that you try to dance around
a topic to try to get to this or to try to hint
at right. So let's make this concrete with an
example. Let's say you have an employee who is just
not performing well they're not doing a good job.
Either you can complement their work and and point
out the good things that they do do or you can sit
them down and say, "Hey, my expectation is actually
that this role is here", this is gonna maybe be
an uncomfortable conversation but you're actually
totally not meeting expectations right now. However,
and this is where intention comes in as an anchor.
However, I would really love to work with you to
meet those expectations if you're willing if
you're interested. So, do you see how we pointed
out something that was really hard we ripped a
band-aid off. But we also came back around and
said I want to be on your team though. Will you
be on my team and that's the intention part
of this when your intention includes the needs of
others and actually benefits other people. You can
rip as many band-aids as you want off. If your
intentions are to uplift that person. Now, if you
want to get to the heart of the matter and your
intention has that actually ripped somebody down
then you can't or there's no way to hide that or
fluff that like, you know giving feedback in the
the sandwich format of I'll give good feedback
and then bad feedback and then good feedback.
Not really that useful. Now, everything
I showed up to this point is useful but
what I'm about to share with you is like is
it it's the golden gem. It's the nugget.
It's what separates really great
facilitators from like okay facilitators.
It is the ability to recognize that there is always
something happening while something is happening.
Which sounds kind of ridiculous but track
with me for a minute. So in a conversation
there's two levels that are happening up here
there's content. There's what you're actually
saying. There's the words that are being said the
sentences that are being strung together and then
all the while that's that conversation's going on
there's something happening and I would call that
process and process is literally everything else.
It's all the music behind the words. It's the
unspoken emotions. It's the unsaid thoughts. It's
the tensioner dynamic between these two people.
It's the past comment that somebody said
somebody's still holding a grudge against.
All the whole pro all team dynamics. It's the
fact that only men are speaking in a meeting
and there's no opportunity for anybody else to
speak or only people at the top of the hierarchy
are speaking and there's no invitation for the
quieter folks or the folks further down on the
rung. All those dynamics that's process and
if you want to get to the point in conversation
become a master at oscillating between the two.
Go down to process bring it whatever is happening or
whatever you're noticing up into the content and
actually talk about it. So take a break from the
content of your meeting to bring process and say
hey everybody this is happening right now. What do
we want to do about it or you can make a decision.
Hey, this is happening right now. I'm recognizing
that only 3 out of 10 of you are really
contributing and we're not leaving much space
and the three of us aren't leaving much space for
the seven of you to contribute and so I'd actually
love to take five minutes to fully pause and write
down our thoughts about this and then I'd love to
hear the voices that haven't been heard so far.
So you duck down into process you bring it
up and you acknowledge and steer right into that
curve right into that dynamic. It's oscillating
between content and process. If you want to deep
dive in content process in the last chapter of ask
powerful questions me and Will's book. We unpack
some advanced tools on how to create conversations
that matter. This last chapter could be a book
of its own it's so densely rich with really
practical tools to help your gatherings be so much
better. I'm Chad Littlefield, have an awesome day.